what are your preferred pronouns uh
zazem
oh i've never heard those before what
are they uh they're what's known as
neopronouns
what are neopronouns
they're basically your own custom
pronouns anything can really be a
pronoun it's true how do i use them um
it depends on the person and their
pronouns
zazem follows a similar spelling to they
in them and even similar grammar rules
like zerenzair zay zem zem self zers
things like that new pronouns are just
you're making
is what i'm getting from this
and we're all supposed to just pretend
this is normal i just you know i i just
felt so you know marginalized by
typical human language that i've created
a new set of terms in which i prefer to
be referred to as
and also
those are my new pronouns
oh